once a popular hub for football fans in
Ukraine shakhtar donetsky stadium is
evidence of how much has changed since
Russia's special military operation
began
these days it's a deserted monument at
the entrance to the volatile Keith
District in unisk
known also askewsky live here as a
constant fight for survival there are no
warning sirens so if you hear the sound
of shelling then you're among the lucky
ones you've survived
it's very hard very hard no water no
light it's very hard a lot of shelling
last week there was a missile that
landed 10 meters away
Karina is a familiar face in kievski she
doesn't have a home and roams the
streets we ask who she supports in the
war
I'm not loyal to Ukraine or Russia I'm
loyal to myself before the War I used to
be a sportswoman since the war though
the only exercise I do is drinking
alcohol damaged and destroyed buildings
lined the roads from kievski to
kurbishovski
thank you
the toll of the war is most evident on
the facade of the district's buildings
one of the last few Still Standing is
this mosque the only one in dunyatzke
there's constant shelling thank God as
long as we are alive there used to be
three of us working here one stepped on
a mine the other left
[Music]
sometimes only a few streets separate
life and death although the sound of
shelling and gunfire can be heard
throughout dunyetsk there are some areas
like here in the city center where
people go about their daily lives as
usual shops and cafes are open and it's
difficult to believe that battles have
taken place just a few kilometers away
as the sun goes down and darkness sets
in the city's contrasts are less obvious
people take shelter in their homes
United in the uncertainty of another
night of conflict